damit kommen wir zum nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt da geht es um die
sicherheit informationstechnischer
systeme und zwar soll das bundesamt für
sicherheit etwas ausgebaut werden es
soll nicht 100 neue stellen wirkung und
auch neue zugriffsrechte bisher ist es
so dass mit reiber kritischer
infrastruktur also die sich zum beispiel
um die wasser und energieversorgung
kümmern dass diese unternehmen ihre it
sicherheitsmaßnahmen vom bundesamt für
sicherheit absegnen lassen müssen und
künftig sollen dass mehr unternehmen
oder betreiber machen sollen und zwar
unternehmen von besonderen öffentlichen
interesse
der gesetzentwurf kommt aus dem
innenministerium und bundesinnenminister
horst seehofer wird hier auch als erstes
zu dem thema sprechen
herr präsident meine damen und herren
die polizeiliche kriminalstatistik die
ich letzte woche vorgestellt habe weist
eindeutig aus die gefährdungslage im
cyber raum ist sehr hoch die technische
entwicklung ist rasant
die cyber angriffe werden immer
intelligenter und der schaden wird immer
größer daher brauchen wir nicht nur eine
ständige wachsamkeit sondern wir müssen
auch unsere schutzmechanismen anpassen
das derzeit gültige it sicherheits
gesetz aus dem jahre 2015 stammt aus dem
jahr 2015
das upgrade auf das sicherheitsgesetz 20
was heute verabschiedet werden soll ist
daher dringend geboten
mit dem gesetz stärken wir die
cybersicherheit in deutschland drei
zentralen bereichen wirtschaft
verbraucherschutz und des bundes erstens
wirtschaft wieder sorgen für die
cybersicherheit in den fünf geben wo
viel mobilfunknetzen
die netzbetreiber müssen vorgegebene
hohe sicherheitsanforderungen erfüllen
kritische komponenten müssen
zertifiziert werden
der einsatz von kritischen komponenten
kann untersagt werden wenn ein
hersteller nicht erforderliche
vertrauenswürdigkeit besitzt
zweitens das bsi die hat das bsi ist die
sicherheitsbehörde des bundes auf dem
gebiet der cyber sicherheit genießt auch
wie ich immer wieder feststellen darf
nicht nur national sondern auch
international höchste anerkennung und
dieses bsi erhält die zuständigkeit
künftig auch für den verbraucherschutz
das heißt für die allgemeine bevölkerung
und hier besonders zu erwähnen ist dass
wir in it sicherheits kennzeichen bei
produkten einführen was für die
bevölkerung eine wichtige hilfe sein
wird
drittens der bund muss seine eigene
schützen
das bsi wird daher künftig
mindeststandards für die bundesbehörde
verbindlich festlegen und effektiver
kontrollieren und nachdem es da immer
wieder eine diskussion gibt möchte ich
auch heute wieder anbieten
denn der deutsche bundestag zu der
auffassung kommen sollten dass wir bei
der it-sicherheit für sie auch noch
einen beitrag leisten sollen und können
dann werden wir da jederzeit bereit
das gesetz macht deutschland sicher im
netz widerstandsfähiger gegen betrug und
erpressung gegen wirtschaftsspionage
gegen die stabilisierung zum beispiel
gegen blinde zerstörungswut wir schützen
mit diesem gesetz den einzelnen nutzer
sowie die allgemeinheit und wir schützen
die privatsphäre sowie die wirtschaft
ich bedanke mich nach einem langen viel
geduld erforderlich im
gesetzgebungsverfahren vor allem bei den
regierungsfraktionen für die gute
zusammenarbeit und nicht zuletzt für die
zuletzt vorgenommenen änderungen an dem
gesetzentwurf
es war schon eine gute vorlage
aber sie ist durch diese änderungen noch
besser geworden
ich danke
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das und die erste erwiderung gibt es von
der digital politischen sprecherin
joanna krupa aus der afg fraktion hier
in der zweiten und dritten lesung zum
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung über
die höhe und der sicherheit
informationstechnischer systeme
[Applaus]
herr präsident werte kollegen völlig
ungenügend bereits im jetzigen stand
überholt falscher focus strategielos
schlechte einbindung von wissenschaft
und zivilgesellschaft ein
bürokratiemonster ein
unsicherheitsgefühl das sind nicht meine
worte das sind zitate aus den
stellungnahmen der sachverständigen zum
sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 das heute hier und
jetzt im bundestag beschlossen werden
soll
selten wurde ein gesetz in einer
öffentlichen anhörung so zerrissen wie
dieses selbst die sachverständigen der
cdu csu und der spd ließen kein gutes
haar an den vorschlägen
das muss man sich mal vorschlägen da
doch fachleute über zwei jahre an einem
gesetz ehrung und heraus kommt ein
entwurf dass die eigenen
sachverständigen die hände über dem kopf
zusammenschlagen meine damen und herren
natürlich kamen auch
verfassungsrechtliche bedenken auf das
ist ja ein trauriger fällt bei dieser
regierung mit dem grundgesetz hat sie es
nicht so das haben wir auch am mittwoch
bei der verabschiedung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes gesehen
aber zurück zum sogenannten
sicherheitsgesetz dieses gesetz wird
alles erreichen nur keine konsequente
erhöhung des sicherheitsniveaus der
it-systeme die vorschläge der
interessensvertreter wurden kaum und
wenn nur in abgeschwächter form
übernommen
diese regierung ist in dieser sache
schlichtweg beratungsresistent und das
kann auch in diesem fall die sicherheit
unseres landes gefährden
dabei hätte man es von anfang an besser
machen können und müssen das erste
sicherheit die sicherheits gesetz
schreibt eine evaluierung fest vor
die afg hat genau das auch in ihrem
antrag gefordert aber sie werte
bundesregierung haben es unterlassen aus
erfahrung zu lernen aus dem vorgänger
gesetz zu analysieren was funktioniert
und was nicht was sinn gemacht hat und
was nicht
und das resultat ist nun ein gesetz das
dem digitalen verbraucherschutz in
keiner weise gerecht wird weil das
fundament fehlt der wehr von afg aber
nicht kritisieren sondern natürlich auch
gestalten wollen haben wir wie
angekündigt zahlreiche anträge und
änderungsanträge 1
im gegensatz zu den bühnen die zwar viel
gemeckert aber zum schluss nicht
geliefert haben
sie stellen hier tatsächlich einen alten
antrag aus dem jahr 2010 bei zu mehr hat
es nicht gereicht in diesem antrag
fordern sie die regierung auf ein neues
sicherheitsgesetz vorzulegen also genau
das was wir hier gerade beschließen das
ist nicht nur ein bisschen peinlich
platte kollege das ist richtig peinlich
aber wo grün ist es eben viel show wenig
schein für schein und wenig echte
verantwortungsvolle politik meine damen
und herren verantwortungsloses übrigens
auch das wegducken der regierung in
sachen netzausbau sie hat es in diesem
gesetz unterlassen eine eindeutig
politische entscheidung zu treffen ob
staatsnahe netzwerkausrüster aus
undemokratischen ländern ab netzausbau
unserer städtischen fünf die
infrastruktur beteiligt bleiben dürfen
genau diese entscheidung verlangen wir
aber von ihnen ihr sinne von unserer
digital souveränität des weiteren
fordern wir unter anderem eine präzise
der definition kritischer komponenten
durch verweis auf das tkg der stand der
technik soll nicht nur von bsi sondern
gemeinsam mit dem iso et cetera
entwickelt werden das bmg muss kritische
komponenten untersagen wenn ein
hersteller nicht vertrauenswürdig ist
ein kann leicht an dieser stelle nicht
ausufern
das bsi muss zu einer starken
verbraucherschutz behörde ausgebaut
werden und so krisen die aktionspläne
für die katastrophen ausarbeiten
wir wollen eine konsolidierung der
mittlerweile sehr zahlreichen die
sicherheitsgesetze da deren
wechselwirkung mittlerweile zum komplex
werden und das wiederum die
it-sicherheit und die wirtschaftlichkeit
besucht und zum schluss möchten wir
sicherstellen dass für das
sicherheitsgesetz zeitpunkt 0 zudem ja
jetzt schon gespräche laufen möglichst
frühzeitig und umfänglich alle
interessierten kreise mit einbezogen
werden und die gestaltung des
ordnungsrahmens für die it-sicherheit in
zukunft eine verantwortlichen
bundesministerium für digitalisierung
und cyber sicherheit übertragen wird
interessant ist ihren schließungs antrag
liebe regierungsparteien dass ich den
dreien so ließ als ob sie es tatsächlich
verstanden hätten aber eine
absichterklärung es sind besser zu
machen das sagt
eben nicht das hätte in diesem gesetz
passieren müssen und das ist es nicht
und daher kann ich leider sagen chance
verschenkt liebe regierung mit diesem
gesetz werden sie die aktive sicherheit
in deutschland nicht gerecht nicht
gerecht im gegenteil
an manchen stellen gefährt sich sogar
und daher werden wir von der fdp
dieses gesetz ablehnen vielen dank
folien hier online portal ist du nochmal
auf die anträge der afc fraktion
eingegangen
die hier ebenfalls zur abstimmung stehen
jetzt muss ich noch mal nachschauen oder
ob sie erst überwiesen werden
genau das sehen auch zur abstimmung
stehen und nächster redner ist sebastian
hartmann aus der spd fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren ich frage der
it-sicherheit ist die frage der
nationalen souveränität die ist
voranschreitende digitalisierung macht
deutlich dass wir als regierung aber
auch als parlament gefragt sind zu
handeln und das meine damen und herren
dem sind wir nachgekommen der minister
offenes wort es seit ewigkeiten gebrauch
zwischen dem zweiten und dem dritten
referentenentwurf ein jahr ist ins land
gegangen und tatsächlich sind in der
anhörung in der öffentlichen anhörung
deutliche kritik punkte genannt worden
wir die regierungsfraktionen haben dem
genau zugehört und so ist dieser
gesetzentwurf im wesentlichen auch
verändert worden und ich kann für die
spd-bundestagsfraktion erklären wir
haben in wesentlichen punkten unsere
auffassung auch durchgesetzt und ich
danke dem koalitionspartner dass er dem
aufruf folgten aufgebaut
im mittelpunkt steht ein gestärktes
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik personell und
finanziell aber es braucht auf der
anderen seite auch eine klare aufgaben
beschreiben damit es seiner neuen rolle
insbesondere mit dem blick auf den
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher schutz
nachkommen kann
wenn jetzt schwachstellen genannt werden
dann ist die öffentlichkeit zu
informieren auch ohne benehmen mit
anderen sicherheitsbehörden ist geht
darum insgesamt die sicherheit in der
informationstechnik durchzusetzen ist es
keine frage des ob sondern es muss
gemacht werden
und damit ist die öffentlichkeit
informieren das bundesamt wird damit in
der entsprechenden unabhängigkeit
gestärkt als selbstständige behörde das
ist ein wesentliches ziel gemäß aber
andere mängel im gesetzentwurf die
hätten doch zu wesentlich mehr
verwerfungen noch geführt nämlich der
frage wenn wir die kritischen
komponenten den kritischen
infrastrukturen an
wir haben uns durchgesetzt als es um die
frage gegen ganz klar die technischen
fragen der sicherheit nämlich der
zertifizierung entsprechender
komponenten zu trennen von der
entscheidenden frage der politischen
vertrauenswürdigkeit von herstellern
damit auch die wirtschaft klar weiß das
sind die rahmenbedingungen an denen wir
das messen und wir als parlament wir
geben diese ordnung vor deren danach die
behörden folgen werden indem nämlich
auch gefragt wird wie schaut es denn im
herstellerland aus wie schaut es bei
beherrschungs verhältnis von
entsprechenden produzenten aus und wir
haben etwas als wesentliches noch
abgestellt was in dem regierungsentwurf
überhaupt nicht ausreichend geregelt
es geht nämlich nicht meine damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
nicht nur um die frage was ist denn vor
der entscheidung über den einbau einer
kritischen komponenten sondern wir
regeln jetzt auch den fall
was ist wenn diese kritischen
komponenten in den kritischen
infrastrukturen verbaut worden sind wenn
möglicherweise ein hersteller seinen
pflichten nicht mehr nachkommt
entsprechende updates zur verfügung zu
stellen oder eben dem auch nicht
rechnung zu tragen was du jetzt
eindeutig in das gesetz geschrieben
haben nämlich genaue schutzziele
vertraulichkeit verfügbarkeit und
integrität entsprechend in der
it-sicherheit
meine damen und herren wir kommen damit
unserer verantwortung als parlament nach
natürlich hätte man sich mehr vorstellen
können und es sind tatsächlich von der
demokratischen opposition auch einiges
an vorschlägen noch eingebracht
offenes wort werden uns noch eine
stärkere unabhängigkeit vorstellen
können aber wir haben auch etwas
eingebaut an das gesetz was deutlich
wenn man die entgegennahme eines
berichtes zur lage der it-sicherheit in
den nächsten jahren
zukünftig wird es nicht nur alle paar
jahre irgend eine evaluierung geben und
wir sind ja jetzt schon mit dem ep
sicherheitsgesetz 2.0 lange vor dem
zeitpunkt wo es eigentlich hätte diese
evaluierung geben sollen sondern
zukünftig wird an den ausschuss für
inneres und heimat nicht nur dieser
bericht übergeben sondern auch über die
fortentwicklung des rechts automatisch
gerichtet und wir als gesetzgeber
darüber informiert wie wird denn mit den
neuen befugnissen umgegangen die wir der
regierung als parlament worauf
bürgerinnen und bürger wirtschaft und
verbände an klaren anspruch haben wie
wird mit diesen neuen ermächtigung
umgegangen um auch dann unter erich
lange vor dem ablauf einer solchen
evaluierung unserer verantwortung
nachzukommen bestmögliche gesetze zu
schreibt für die erhöhung der
it-sicherheit liebe kollegen natürlich
wird ist für den neuen gesetzgeber auch
fragen geben wenn es um entschädigungen
geht wenn wir schauen ob diese
kritischen komponenten tatsächlich in
der anwendbarkeit zukünftig untersagt
wird das werden wir genau betrachten
müssen wir werden auch betrachten müssen
was sich auf europäischer ebene tut aber
hier haben wir dem bsi klare vorgaben
gemacht was die definition des standes
der technik angeht oder entsprechend die
fortentwicklung meine damen und herren
wir laden sie herzlich ein das gesetz zu
beschließen und sind froh dass wir uns
in wesentlichen punkten durchsetzen
können hartmann war das führungstrikot
information
nächster redner ist manuel höferlin er
sitzt für die fdp fraktion im ausschuss
digitale agenda und ist auch der
vorsitzende in diesem ausschuss auch ein
entschließungsantrag eingereicht der
auch hier nach der debatte abgestimmt
wird
gute herr präsident meine damen und
herren die it-sicherheit ist die
achillesferse unserer modernen
gesellschaft ich habe das schon an
vielen stellen gesagt und man könnte
jetzt sagen nach zwei jahren dieser
beratung des gesetzes wäre endlich ein
gesetz herausgekommen das den namen auch
verdient hat die sicherheitsgesetze
eigentlich müsste man es nach den
letzten tagen wo sie auf den letzten
metern der koalition mal wieder geeinigt
haben wie das von letzten drücker einen
ausschuss bekommen haben etwas spöttisch
sagen das ist eher dass gute
internetgesetz 2.0
das würde sein treffer lich der
trefflichsten beschreiben leider ist es
bedauerlich denn es gibt eine große
diskrepanz zwischen dem was sie in den
zwei jahren in dieses sicherheitsgesetz
hineingeschrieben haben und dem was sie
auf den letzten drücker als
regierungsfraktionen in einen
entschließungsantrag gegossen haben mit
einem auftrag an die nächste
bundesregierung die it-sicherheit in
deutschland gestalten werden soll das
ist allerdings nicht ihre aufgabe ihre
aufgabe ist es gesetze zu machen mit der
mehrheit zu beschließen und nicht
aufträge an die bundesregierung die dann
irgendwann mal kommen aufzuschreiben
so bleibt das alte sicherheitsgesetz
leider ein flickenteppich es ist eine
wirkliche strategie die cybersicherheit
konsequent zu ende gedacht werden soll
nicht gehabt deswegen haben wir im
ausschuss auch zahlreiche
änderungsanträge eingebracht ich habe
das in der ersten lesung angekündigt und
auch einen entschließungsantrag
dazugeschrieben wohlgemerkt in ihrem
entschließungsantrag stehen einige dinge
drin die deckungsgleich seien deswegen
wir uns zum entschließungsantrag auch
enthalten werden aber es fehlen zum
beispiel agiere sicherheitsmaßnahme ist
fehlt zum beispiel transparenter
kommunikation ich will auch nur etwas
blick stichpunktartig sagen was ich in
der vergangenheit auch schon immer
wieder gesagt habe die offenlegung von
sicherheitslücken konsequent alle
bundesbehörden müssen sicherheitslücken
dem bsi melden und die müssen konsequent
verantwortlich geöffnet werden
geschlossen werden damit sie nicht offen
bleiben
damit sie auch im innenministerium
nachher nicht für andere zwecke genutzt
werden können weil das schädigt die
seiler sicherheit das ist nicht in
diesem gesetz drin
es gibt immer noch ausnahme von
meldepflichten und für die wirtschaft
echt ein problem es gibt immer noch
keinen qualitativen rückkanal der
wirtschaft einen nutzen hinsichtlich der
cyber sicherheit bringt es gibt dafür
jede menge meldepflichten jede menge
bürokratie aber eben keinen nutzen für
die unternehmen nach er direkt das habe
ich mein internet sicherheit ein
schuldiger ist schon bereit die
sicherheitsgesetze 10 sozusagen schon
kritisiert und es bleibt leider jetzt
weiter dabei hätte hätte hilft uns nicht
weiter wie gesagt ihr
entschließungsantrag nimmt einige dinge
ins visier stadt diesem aufkleber auf
software sicherheits kennzeichen hätten
sie besser mal über die haftung von
herstellern nachgedacht das ist das
relevante was machen wir denn in zukunft
wenn boxen ohne bildschirm ohne tastatur
auskommen aber keine sicherheits updates
eingespielt werden
das merkt man erst später wir haben mal
gesagt haften stadthälften machen sie
keinen aufkleber drauf sondern nehmen
sie die unternehmen in die haftung dann
wird das auch besser wir haben einen und
herren das alles ist nicht überzeugen
sie werden das ablehnen müssen es gibt
ein silberstreif am horizont
bundestagswahl kann sich das ändern
herzlichen dank den zeitplan unter
anderen angesprochen denn eigentlich
sollte dieser gesetzentwurf tatsächlich
schon vor gut einem jahr vor der
sommerpause 2020 in den bundestag kommen
aber es gab zwischen den
koalitionspartnern diskussionen und auch
innerhalb der fraktionen war man sich im
nicht eigentlich blick verspricht
sprecherin für netzpolitik und die
sicherheit der linksfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
wir reden heute über das zweite
sicherheitsgesetz also ein gesetz zur
informationstechnik um das zu übersetzen
mit seinen vielfältigen hardware und
software optionen die digitale
entwicklung gerast
das erste sicherheitsgesetz hat zwei
jahre auf dem buckel und galt übrigens
expertinnen und experten eher als
unsicherheits gesetz um das den
bürgerinnen und bürgern zu erklären wir
reden hier nicht über irgendwelche
spezialthemen zum beispiel die
allgemeine energie und wasserversorgung
basiert längst auf it-systeme
das heißt alle bürgerinnen und bürger
sind von den dingen über die wir heute
reden betroffen
insofern ist ein zweites gesetz
überfällig oder anders gesagt die
fraktion die linke hält es für notwendig
da sagt sagt wiederum nichts darüber aus
ob wir dem gesetz auch zustimmen
wir werden es nicht tun denn die mängel
überdecken das nötige und sie haben mit
ihrem entschließungsantrag übrigens
gleich ein großteil der mängelliste mit
geliefert was in diesem zweiten
sicherheitsgesetz hätte geregelt werden
müssen
das beginnt damit dass nicht evaluiert
wurde also geprüft wurde wie wirksam
ob er möglicherweise auch fehlerhaft das
erste sicherheitsgesetz war beim nunmehr
zweiten beklagen experten dass sie und
ihr wissen nicht gefragt bauen das finde
ich freundlich formuliert politisch
fatal es hier überhaupt diese eklatante
strategie und ziellosigkeit auf herr
minister bei dem hof der uns hier auf
den tisch kam insofern jahr die fraktion
haben daran gearbeitet aber aus meiner
sicht nicht genug das bundesamt
für die sicherheit in der
informationstechnik bsi soll mit diesem
gesetz weitere befugnisse erhalten so
weit so gut
allerdings muss es informationen über
bekannte erkannte sicherheitslücken
mitnichten vollständig öffentlich machen
das ist intransparent und wenig
vertrauenswürdig und übrigens einige
phasen wohl für die kritische
infrastruktur als auch für die
persönliche sicherheit jedes einzelnen
bürgers jeder einzelnen bürgerinnen
schließlich bleibt das bsi dem bmi wie
das innenministerium nach geordnet die
linke fordert mehr unabhängigkeit und
selbständigkeit fazit die linke lehnt
den vorliegenden gesetzentwurf ab der
bundesinnenminister jetzt nicht für
meine fraktionen sondern in einem
anderen amt ich habe ihr angebot sehr
wohl gehört wir arbeiten sehr gut als
deutsche bundestag mit dem bsi zusammen
und wir sind dankbar für diese
zusammenarbeit im interesse sowohl des
parlaments als auch natürlich des
vertrauens und der transparenz aber es
bleibt dabei wir sind angehörige
unterschiedlicher verfassungsorgan
vielen dank
eben hat es also wolfgang kubicki der
momentanen besetzung leitender
bundestags-vizepräsident hier noch
einmal erwähnt petra pau hat zwar jetzt
für die linke gesprochen aber sie ist
eben auch bundestagsvizepräsidentin und
hat in dieser funktion ihrer rede noch
einen paten orte hinzugefügt
entschuldigt sehr präsent meine damen
und herren der minister hat gesagt die
it-sicherheit ist das zentrale
sicherheitspolitische thema unserer zeit
und in dem bereich brennt die hütte
lichterloh und umso unverständlicher ist
dass so wenig passiert ist die letzten
jahre frau kollegin kuder sie haben
vollkommen recht wir fordern seit vielen
jahren all die guten dinge die endlich
kommen müssten
ich ziehe sie mal auf klare
zuständigkeiten innerhalb der
bundesregierung neue strukturen zur
erkennung hybrider bedrohungslagen gute
rechtsgrundlagen zum beispiel für die
zusammenarbeit im cyber-abwehrzentrum
meldepflicht für sicherheitslücken
durchgehende
ende-zu-ende-verschlüsselung neue
haftungsregelung weniger
massenüberwachung mehr freie und offene
software resilienz und redundanz und so
weiter und sofort alles anträge die wir
hier geliefert haben die groko hat es
nicht gemacht und deswegen waren die
letzten vier jahre für die it-sicherheit
schlechte jahre meine damen und herren
das ding sollte ja ganz am anfang ist es
hier gesagt worden am anfang der
legislatur kommen weil die hütte
lichterloh brennt und weil wir jede
woche praktisch im parlament diese fälle
hier haben und 4 von brennende hütte zu
brennen der hütte laufen aber statt
sozusagen über eine schutzmauer eine
brandschutzmauer zu reden haben wir uns
oder sich die große koalition viel mehr
in irgendwelchen huawei debatten
verfangen alles sehr unproduktiv jetzt
kommen sie hier in der letzten kurve der
legislatur mal wieder um die ecke 500
seiten 48 stunden frist für alle
beteiligten verbände und die ngo ist und
kein wunder dass sie praktisch alle
verbände gegen sich aufgebracht haben
mit dem verfahren
harsche kritik von den sachverständigen
und zwar nicht nur von denen der
opposition sondern der großen koalition
der sachverständige professor karin
ausgewiesener fachmann in vielen
bereichen spricht von einem anti
sicherheitsgesetz von einem anti
sicherheitsgesetz die
familienunternehmen sprechen von einem
unsicherheits gesetz und genauso ist es
meine damen und herren auf alle
zentralen fragen die im raum stehen
keine antworten vorratsdatenspeicherung
keine lösung für die ansätze oder
ansätze für rechtliche oder tatsächliche
online durchsuchung noch immer handel
mit sicherheitslücken noch immer eine
völlig ungeklärte haltung zur
verschlüsselung ja die im
koalitionsvertrag rein gegossener
widerspruch sicherheit mit
verschlüsselung und sicherheit trotz
verschlüsselung so ambivalent ist die
bundesregierung in diesem ganz ganz
zentralen sicherheitsthema und deswegen
das ist einfach zu wenig und so können
sie hier eigentlich nicht am ende der
legislatur das abliefern das sie hier
leider abliefern
es ist gesagt worden die
berichterstatter der großen koalition
reden schon davon was man in der
nächsten legislatur machen muss es mich
erinnert das alles an einen schild in
der küche meines onkels auf dem stand ab
morgen wird gespart da stand es 30 jahre
lang und genauso ist ihre
sicherheitspolitik im it-bereich so wird
das nichts meine damen und herren
herzlichen dank
ganz im tim platz und stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90
sekunden hat hier gesprochen auch die
grünen haben hier anträge eingereicht
die danach hier abgestimmt werden
drei redner haben wir aber noch in der
debatte der nächste leben du ist
christoph stil er sitzt im
innenausschuss für die unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident werde
kolleginnen und kollegen
drei jahre hat arbeit voller widerstände
voller widersprüche und auch voller
neuer erkenntnisse in drei minuten
redezeit zu packen ist gar nicht so
einfach
und die vorredner haben auch einige
punkte angesprochen die ich jetzt gerne
natürlich alle auf arbeiten würde aber
dafür fehlt mir einfach schlichtweg die
zeit
wir haben und das hat horst seehofer
bereits gesagt in diesem gesetzentwurf
vom kabinett noch mal erheblich
nachgeschärft als parlament und wir
können wirklich selbstbewusst heute
sagen das ist eine sternstunde des
parlaments denn wir haben jetzt ein
echtes sicherheitsgesetz was diesen
namen auch verdient und darüber kann man
sich tatsächlich wirklich mal freuen
dies alles wäre nicht möglich gewesen
ohne die unterstützung vieler
kolleginnen und kollegen viele experten
innerhalb und außerhalb des parlaments
bei denen möchte ich mich an dieser
stelle sehr herzlich bedanken und ich
möchte namentlich heraus greifen wir
auch das gehört an so einem tag dazu
norbert philipp am tor michael brandt
und auch sebastian hartmann von der
koalitionsfraktion mit dem wir sehr gut
zusammengearbeitet haben ich denke dafür
kann man sich wirklich mal bedanken
wesentliche merkmale in diesem gesetz
die ich heraus greifen würde eine wo
einige wurden schon genannt es ist die
stärkung des bsi zu einer echten
nationalen cyber sicherheitsbehörde die
zukünftig auch noch die aufgaben des
verbraucherschutzes übernehmen wird es
ist das eigentlich sicherheits
kennzeichen was angesprochen wurde
und es ist natürlich auch die klärung
endlich der 5d frage und hier haben wir
wirklich etwas neues erschaffen was so
in europa einmalig ist denn die
sicherheitsüberprüfung über zugesetzt
zukünftig zwei stufen enthalten eine
technische überprüfung und die
langersehnte politische überprüfung und
einige haben im vorfeld gesagt das ist
kein lex huawei das ist richtig denn die
sicherheitsanforderungen gelten für alle
unternehmen gleichwohl die sich
zukünftig an 5g netzausbau beteiligen
wollen richtig ist aber auch dass
unternehmen als nicht vertrauenswürdig
eingestuft werden können wie zb unter
der kontrolle von autoritären staaten
stehen oder die sich der kontrolle von
autoritären staaten nicht entziehen
können weil es dort kein
funktionierendes rechtssystem gibt und
diese unternehmen können in zukunft vom
netzausbau ausgeschlossen werden und das
ist ein deutlicher sicherheitsgewinn für
unsere bundesrepublik deutschen meine
damen und herren und 1 möchte ich in
diesem zusammenhang auch sagen weil es
ja diese debatte auch teilweise stark
erholt hat natürlich ist es ein
unterschied ob wir hersteller aus europa
zum netzausbau zu lassen aus den
vereinigten staaten aus südkorea oder
china
und wenn die kommunistische partei in
china weiterhin so agiert wie sie es
momentan tut in hongkong wie sie es tut
im umgang mit den uiguren wie sie es tut
im verhältnis zu teilen und mit den
zunehmend aggressiven expansion
versuchen im ostchinesischen meer
dann habe ich große zweifel daran ob
hersteller die genau aus diesem land
kommen und zum großen teilen auch von
der kommunistischen partei chinas
kontrolliert sind zukünftig
vertrauenswürdiger hersteller sein
können die wir hier in deutschland zu
lassen und deshalb ja ich komme zum
schluss
und deshalb gibt es eben jetzt auch die
möglichkeit im nachgang die
vertrauenswürdigkeit solche hersteller
zu überprüfen und im schlimmsten fall
auch zu entziehen
heute ist ein guter tag für die it
sicherheit in deutschland und ich kann
nur dafür werben diesem gesetz
zuzustimmen herzlichen dank als nächste
reden hat das wort herr kollege
christoph matschie spd
[Applaus]
herr präsident werte kolleginnen und
kollegen die informationstechnologie
spielt nicht nur für das funktionieren
von wirtschaft und gesellschaft eine
zentrale rolle
das haben wir heute mehrfach gehört sie
ist auch ein wichtiger baustein im
geopolitischen wettbewerb und deshalb
müssen wir erstens dafür sorgen dass
infrastruktur technisch sicher
funktioniert und dass die daten sicher
sind und wir müssen zweitens dafür
sorgen dass wir selbst in der lage sind
solche infrastrukturen zu bauen und zu
betreiben oder in problematische
abhängigkeiten zu kommen denn
abhängigkeit heißt immer auch
erpressbarkeit es geht also einerseits
um unsere technologische und politische
souveränität und zum anderen um die
sicherheit unserer daten
wir haben diese debatte am beispiel des
ausbaus der fünf genäht intensiv geführt
über die letzten jahre nämlich unter
zwei fragestellungen wie verhindern wir
dass daten abgegriffen werden oder dass
das netz durch angriffe kompromittiert
wird und wie verhindern wir dass sich
europa immer stärker abhängig macht zum
beispiel von anbietern aus china und mit
dem sicherheitsgesetz geben wir nach
zugegeben ziemlich langer und intensiver
debatte aber heute eine klare antwort
die bundesregierung kann zukünftig den
einsatz von komponenten untersagen wenn
der hersteller dieser technik
unmittelbar oder mittelbar von der
regierung oder sonstigen staatlichen
stellen eines drittstaates abhängt und
in der begründung ist das noch mal
klargestellt dass es sich dabei nicht
nur um eine gesellschaftsrechtliche oder
finanzielle kontrolle sondern auch um
sonstige möglichkeiten der
auf unternehmen handeln solche
unternehmen wollen wir in unseren netzen
zukünftig nicht und der einsatz kann
auch untersagt werden wenn er nicht im
einklang steht mit den
sicherheitspolitischen zielen der
bundesrepublik deutschland der
europäischen union oder der nato und das
hat der kollege dann steht eben auch
noch mal deutlich gemacht
sebastian hartmann vorhin auch den ich
beiden auch noch mal danken möchte als
berichterstatter
es können auch komponenten verboten
werden die schon eingebaut sind wenn ein
hersteller nicht vertrauenswürdig ist
und deshalb mit den regelungen im
sicherheitsgesetz folgen wir einem
europäischen weg den vorschlägen der
fünf geht toolbox der europäischen union
wir geben ein klares signal an
wirtschaft und verbraucher wir stärken
die datensicherheit in zukunft sollen
bei kritischer infrastruktur nur
vertrauenswürdige hersteller zum zuge
kommen und wir setzen
wir setzen ein gleichzeitig stärken wir
die digitale souveränität europas in dem
wir vor allem auf europäische anbieter
von it infrastruktur setzen das sichert
unsere handlungsfähigkeit und unsere
jobs dieses gesetz ist ein wichtiger
meilenstein auf dem weg zu besserer
datensicherheit und zu einem starken und
handlungsfähigen europa und deshalb
bitte ich sie um zustimmung herzlichen
dank
und damit kommen wir zum letzten redner
denn danach geht es weiter mit dem
arbeitsmarkt ost wir sehen hier auch
schon dem bundesminister für arbeit und
soziales hubertus heil aber eben eine
rede hören wir noch zum thema sicherheit
informationstechnische systeme und zwar
von tankred schipanski aus der
unionsfraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kollegen und
kollegen viele wortbeiträge in dieser
debatte natürlich zur sicherheit die
sicherheit wir haben das gehört daher
die federführung auch beim
innenausschuss an diesem gesetz habe
aber auch viele kollegen anderer
arbeitsbereiche mitgewirkt christoph
fernziel hat sie schon erwähnt möchte
aber mich ausdrücklich noch mal bei den
digital politik und den
wirtschaftspolitikern gedanken aus deren
blickwinkel billig in dieser debatte
natürlich betonen wie wichtig die
kommunikationsnetze sind das internet
die mobile nutzung die mannigfache
weiterentwicklung sind aus unserem
alltag gar nicht mehr wegzudenken und
jetzt geht bei dieser debatte eben nicht
nur um verbrechen angst und hacker es
geht vielmehr um konkreten nutzen um
wohlstand und um innovationen daher
verein wir in diesem gesetz die
sicherheitspolitischen interessen und
die wirtschaftspolitischen interessen
und lieber manuell höfer liegen deswegen
ist es ein gutes gesetz für das internet
und für die digital politiker stand
dabei immer das thema 5g ausbau ganz
stark im mittelpunkt es ist angeklungen
sicherheit ist wichtig es darf aber
nicht zu einem ausbaustopp unserer tk
infrastruktur führen
und gerade china mit seinen plan zte und
huawei standen dabei immer wieder im
blickfeld dieser diskussion
viele haben ein verbotsgesetz für
chinesische technologie befürchtet von
einem lexa war sogar die rede
und ich möchte hier ganz klar
feststellen dass wir diesen
mit diesem gesetz ausdrücklich nicht
gehen wichtig ist dass wir als parlament
den ausschlaggebenden neuen bsi gesetz
deutlich umgestaltet haben wir haben
jetzt in dieser debatte gehört wir haben
diesen neuen rechts klarer gefasst wir
haben klare zuständigkeiten klare
zeitabläufe und klare abwägung abwägungs
kriterien wichtig war mir aber immer
dass wir als parlament nicht entscheiden
ob eine bestimmte komponente im 5 genäht
technischen anforderungen genügt das ist
sache der experten des bsi
wichtig war mir zudem dass wir im
parlament nicht mit wechselnden
mehrheiten entscheiden bei welchem
hersteller bzw welchem land kann man
komponenten kaufen das sie unter
telekommunikationsunternehmen da etwas
vorschreiben
damit werden wir fachlich schlichtweg
überfordert gewesen liebe kolleginnen
kollegen wir geben als gesetzgeber
lediglich klare kriterien vor die die
exekutive bei der sogenannten
vertrauenswürdigkeit prüfung zu beachten
hat wir greifen keinen abwägungs
ergebnis vor
wir geben nur einen klaren rahmen vor
und als parlament bewerten wir somit
chinesische oder amerikanische anbieter
nicht wir bevorzugen auch keine
europäischen anbieter ein wichtiger fakt
für gleiche wettbewerbsbedingungen
meine damen und herren der
innenausschuss macht in seinem
entschließungsantrag nochmals deutlich
dass wir die praktikabilität des neuen
bsi gesetz evaluieren müssen
es ist wichtig dabei auch zu prüfen
entschädigungsregeln für tk unternehmen
notwendig wären
sollte es zu rückforderungen kommen das
möchte ich an dieser stelle ausdrücklich
noch einmal festhalten und der
innenausschuss betont in seinem antrag
nochmals die europäische einbettung der
gesamtproblematik nationale sonderwege
sind mit diesem gesetz nicht unser ziel
was lange währt wird endlich gut ich
werde somit herzlich um zustimmung zu
diesem gesetz vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich schließe die aussprache willkommen
zur abstimmung über den von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurf zur erhöhung der
sicherheit informationstechnischer
systeme der ausschuss für inneres und
heimat empfiehlt unter buchstabe aus
einer beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache
28844 den gesetzentwurf der
bundesregierung oft den drucksachen
26.100 6 und 26 1921 in der ausschuss
fassung anzunehmen
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
gesetzentwurf in der ausschuss fassung
zustimmen wollen um das handzeichen
danke wer stimmt dagegen danke wer
enthält sich der gesetzentwurf ist damit
in zweiter beratungen mit den stimmen
der koalitionsfraktionen gegen die
stimmen der oppositionsfraktionen
angenommen dritte beratung und
schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die den
gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
danke bestimmt dagegen
[Musik]
danke während hält sich der
gesetzentwurf ist mit den stimmen der
cdu csu fraktion und der spd fraktion
gegen die stimmen der fdp fraktion der
fdp fraktion der fraktion die linke und
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
angenommen
wir sind noch beim tagesordnungspunkt
37a und stimmen nun über den entschieden
über entschließungsanträge ab
entschließungsantrag der produktion
wobei anständig songs anträge die afg
fraktion fordert unter anderem dass das
bundesamt für sicherheit mehr zu einer
verbraucherschutzbehörde wird und ist
zum beispiel eine hotline für bürger
gibt ähnlich wie sie der polizei und der
feuerwehr
wohin sich bürgerinnen und bürger wenden
können entschließungsantrag der
fraktionen der fdp
dieser antrag wurde abgelehnt von
parlament und damit konvention zweiten
antrag der fdp-fraktion die möchte ganz
gern und das interessenskonflikte
ausgelöst aufgelöst werden und deswegen
das bundesamt für sicherheit in nicht
mehr in der zuständigkeit des
bundesinnenministeriums künftig liegt
die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen der
entschließungsantrag ist abgelehnt
tagesordnungspunkt 37 b wir setzen die
abstimmungen zu der beschlussempfehlung
des ausschusses für inneres und hämmert
auf drucksache 28844 fort der ausschuss
empfiehlt unter buchstabe b sah in der
beschlussempfehlung die ablehnung des
antrags der fraktion der ofd auf
drucksache 26 1225 mit dem titel
evaluierung des it sicherheits gesetzes
von 2015 nach gesetzeslage umsetzen und
ergebnisse im sicherheitsgesetz 0
berücksichtigen
wer stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
dann gewählt stimmt dagegen danke wer
enthält sich die beschlussempfehlung es
mit den stimmen der koalitionsfraktionen
der fdp-fraktion der fraktion die linke
und der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
gegen die stimmen der fdp fraktion
angenommen und der buchstabe c seiner
beschlussempfehlung empfiehlt der
ausschuss die ablehnung des antrags der
fraktionen der ofd aufdruck 26 1226 mit
dem titel sicherheitsgesetz wohnungs und
rechtssicherheit für netzbetreiber
herstellen
diese ganzen fordert die fdp fraktion
dass es eine entscheidung vorne der
bundesregierung geben soll ob staatsnah
netzwerkausrüster
in demokratischen staaten am ausbau der
fünf die infrastruktur beteiligt werden
dürfen das war ja eine diskussion wegen
des chinesischen technologiekonzerns wo
sich auch die politiker der
koalitionsfraktionen 1 waren im
gesetzentwurf jetzt der aber eben auch
entschieden
beschlossen wurde ist kein pauschaler
ausschluss umstrittener anbieter
vorgesehen und sich mit dem titel
sicherheit stärken freiheit erhalten
frieden sich diese prägung zu und wird
jetzt abgestimmt die
koalitionsfraktionen und die fdp
fraktion bestimmt dagegen die fraktionen
die linke und bündnis 90/die grünen wer
enthält sich die fdp-fraktion die
beschlussempfehlung ist angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 37 c abstimmung über
die beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses
für inneres unter immer zu dem antrag
der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen mit
dem titel maßnahmen zur gewährleistung
der integrität digitale infrastrukturen
geräte und komponenten für eine größere
digitale souveränität deutschlands und
europas
der ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache
25.000 181 den antrag der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen auf drucksache 16
1049 abzulehnen
wer stimmt für diese beschlussempfehlung
die koalitionsfraktionen wer stimmt
dagegen die fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen wer enthält sich die auf die
fraktion die fdp fraktion und die
fraktion die linke
die beschlussempfehlung ist an